à une certaine distance les uns des
autres mais une nouvelle approche fait
son chemin au même titre qu'on appelle à
la densification des milieux de vie en
ville on densifie également la
plantation des arbres bienvenue dans
l'univers des microphorés
[Musique]
on a des pelles pour ceux qui en ont pas
petit à troupements le long du boulevard
Rosemont à Montréal une vingtaine de
bénévoles s'apprête à planter une forêt
et pas n'importe laquelle
micro forêt vous voyez que c'est
vraiment différent de ce qu'on est
habitué de faire le principe c'est qu'on
plante des très jeunes plats tout petit
une grande densité ici sur 300 mètres
carrés l'équivalent d'un terrain et demi
de tennis 900 petits arbres prendront
racine
[Musique]
si on veut planter trois arbres au mètre
carré aujourd'hui à peu près ce qui est
vraiment différent de nos arbres en
ville où ils sont distancés de 7 mètres
dépendamment de l'espèce et cette forêt
ne sera pas une monoculture loin de là
on y retrouvera 40 espèces différentes
pour la plupart indigènes des mélèzes
des chaînes des carriers
ils sont plantés de manière très dense
pour un peu les inciter à faire à se
faire compétition puis eux ils vont
chercher la lumière c'est pour leur
survie donc ils vont la théorie ceux qui
vont pousser vraiment plus rapidement du
fait qu'on l'a compétition entre eux le
concept des microphores a été développé
par un botaniste japonais Akira Mia WAKI
il constate que les forêts nipponnes
avaient été reboisées au fil des siècles
avec des essences non indigènes plus
productives mais potentiellement moins
résiliente miaouki part alors à la
recherche d'arbres qui avait peu à peu
disparu du paysage sylvicole dans les
années 1960 il recueille des graines
d'arbres près des temples et des
cimetières des lieux qui n'ont jamais
fait l'objet de coupe il se sert des
petites pousses pour reboiser en imitant
le plus possible ce que la nature ferait
au Japon et dans divers pays tropicaux
plus de 1300 sites ont été restaurés
selon sa technique
c'est très bon
de la méthode Miyawaki on laisse les
gens planter les arbres de manière
aléatoire il n'y a pas de canevas
préétabli comme si les graines avaient
été déposées par le vent en amont
l'ingénieur forestière Audrey boulanger
Messier a choisi à la fois des arbres et
des arbustes pour imiter la biodiversité
d'une forêt naturelle à long terme ils
vont pas atteindre la même grandeur le
fait que peut-être qu'il va avoir déjà
un espèce de sous-étage qui va s'établir
sous les grands arbres reste à voir si
ça va bien fonctionner peut-être que le
sous-état je vais être tellement imprimé
qui va finir par mourir avant que on
atteigne la maturité mais ça va être
avoir en tout à Montréal quatre
arrondissements ont aménagé des
microphorés cette année il concept
attire également le secteur privé
nous sommes au bord de l'autoroute à
Boisbriand ce terrain gazonné n'est pas
exactement un haut lieu de biodiversité
mais il s'apprête à changer de vocation
couper du vent rafraîchir l'espace ici
puis donner une meilleure vue aux gens
qui travaillent dans ces bureaux là
parce que ils voient un autoroute
présentement beaucoup plus agréable de
voir une forêt inspirée par un
documentaire sur l'environnement il y a
quelques années Sébastian Doyon voulait
que son entreprise de nettoyage face à
part
on plante les arbres sur le terrain 300
arbres 17 espèces différentes donc
tout le monde met la main à la pâte
ici ce sont les employés qui plantent
les arbres et contrairement à la forêt
de l'arrondissement de Rosemont on ne
laisse pas faire le hasard
le terrain a été quadrillé sans parcelle
d'un mètre carré recevront chacune un
grand arbre un arbuste et un arbrisseau
selon différentes combinaisons d'espèces
pour la prochaine
avant d'être mise en terre on mesure le
diamètre et la hauteur de chacun des
végétaux 25 on va revenir prendre des
mesures du diamètre de la hauteur voir
comment les arbres ont poussé et à
partir de cette différence de croissance
on va pouvoir estimer la quantité de
carbone à la quantité de biomasse qui a
été produite et éventuellement la
quantité de carbone qui a été séquestrée
par les arbres chercheurs en écologie
forestière à l'Université du Québec à
Chicoutimi Charles Marty et bénévoles au
sein de l'OSBL qui supervise ici la
plantation il veut savoir comment se
comporte les différentes combinaisons
d'arbres la plupart des études Miyawaki
donc ce système de mini forêt à forte
densité ont été faites en Asie beaucoup
au Japon il y en a énormément au Japon
en Inde en Asie du Sud-Est mais on
manque on manque un petit peu de recul
il faut on commence à pousse sous nos
climats avec nos sols etc et quelles
espèces sont les mieux adaptées à de
telles densités
une partie de la réponse se trouve ici
on est dans un champ d'agriculture qui
sert à l'enseignement et à la recherche
pour l'université Mégane mais on a cette
petite patte de forêt là qui fait à peu
près pour les six secteurs c'est en 2009
que cette forêt très dense prend racine
à Sainte-Anne de Bellevue
le chercheur à l'imparquette de Lucam
nous l'a fait visiter printemps
il y avait beaucoup de monde on avait
besoin de beaucoup de main d'oeuvre donc
ça fait
12824 arbres à planter plus ceux qui est
important pour conserver un milieu
d'intérieur
très la mise en terre c'est désormais
une vraie forêt quand on pénètre à
l'intérieur le contraste avec le champ
et frappant
il y a beaucoup moins de lumière qu'on
était à l'extérieur la température est
différente il fait froid va pas froid
mais il fait beaucoup plus frais et puis
on voit que il y a plus de plantes au
sol comparées au champ où on était
tantôt très peu en fait c'est même des
petits semis d'arbres ou des espèces
très tolérante à l'ombre qui s'installe
tranquillement et puis ben on voit
beaucoup de branchements et on voit
beaucoup d'arbres morts plus de la
moitié n'ont pas survécu la compétition
pour les ressources comme la lumière ou
l'eau fait que la microphorès
s'éclaircit d'elle-même c'est à partir
de la sixième année que les chercheurs
observent que certains arbres se mettent
à mourir ce qui n’inquiète pas du tout à
l'impact au contraire en plus d'être la
dynamique naturelle d'une forêt c'est
fondamental la santé d'une forêt santé
de façon générale parce qu'on a plein
d'organismes qui sont soit favorisés
soit carrément dépendants des arbres
morts et du bois mort selon qui est au
sol selon qui tient encore debout
on a des champignons qui vont dégrader
le bois qui vont retourner ces
ressources là pour qu'elle soit à
nouveau disponible pour la croissance de
d'autres espèces on a des oiseaux qui
sont bien connus pour nicher dans les
arbres ou se nourrir dans les arbres
morts donc oui il y a toute une
dynamique une forêt c'est loin d'être
que des armes
une hiérarchie s'est installée
dans une dans une forêt donc en haut ce
qu'on a c'est quelques érables et
surtout les plus hauts le boulot à
papier qui est une espèce pionnière qui
s'installe en premier qui va pousser
rapidement ici les arbres sont plantés à
50 cm les uns des autres et on a testé
toutes sortes de combinaisons d'espèces
sur certaines parcelles on a aussi
planté des monocultures avec le recul
les chercheurs constatent que plus les
espèces sont différentes sur une même
parcelle plus celle-ci sont productives
on mélange deux espèces intolérantes à
l'ombre elles ont besoin de la même
ressource c'est-à-dire plein de lumière
en même temps ça fonctionne pas où elles
se font beaucoup de compétition mais si
on mélange deux espèces dont l'une a
besoin de beaucoup de lumière va occuper
de l'espace et l'autre peut se contenter
de moins de lumière en sous-étage ben
ensemble elles vont pousser plus que la
moyenne de leur monoculture respective
c'est ça un effet de biodiversité donc
ensemble elles sont plus
pour exploiter les ressources au bout de
10 ans les chercheurs remarquent une
augmentation de 20% de biomasse sur les
parcelles plus diversifiées mais on est
loin de certains chiffres souvent
avancés lorsqu’il est question des
microphores comme par exemple quel
pousserait 10 fois plus vite quand on
voit 10 fois plus rapide je pourrais pas
me prononcer sur la rapidité mais
probablement que ce jeune âge ils vont
pousser rapidement mais après ça le
chiffrer c'est difficile il faut
toujours comparer 10 fois plus
rapidement que quoi qu'un arbre qu'on
plante habituellement en milieu urbain
ou qu'un arbre qu'on peut qui pousse
naturellement en forêt autre affirmation
souvent énoncée les microforêts
séquestreraient 30 fois plus de carbone
c'est juste pas possible le chef est
juste trop gros et puis je trouve ça
malheureux qu'on mette ça de l'avant
alors que en fait c'est pour d'autres
raisons qu'on devrait les mettre en
place on parle souvent de déficit de
nature on parle souvent d'enfants qui
ont même pas la chance d'aller à au cas
par exemple et la nature qui voit c'est
le parc avec quelques arbres isolés et
puis si on était capable de recréer
quelque chose comme dans lequel on est
ici ça sera déjà ça d'acquis pour pour
ces enfants là dans ces quartiers là
[Musique]
car outre les végétaux et la préparation
du terrain il faut entretenir les lieux
pendant trois ans en désherbant et en
arrosant mais c'est peu pour tous les
services qu'elles rendront comme réduire
les îlots de chaleur ou purifier l'air
c'est un avantage aussi qui pourrait
être mis à profit par les municipalités
de se dire on a un espace vide plutôt
que de passer la tondeuse de mettre des
engrais et bien on va mettre une mini
forêt ça dans trois ans on occupe plus
elle coûte plus rien elle rapporte un
arbre c'est un investissement et non
plus un coup pour une municipalité c'est
vraiment un avantage
[Musique]
dans l'arrondissement de Rosemont
l'aventure des microphores a débuté en
2021 un an plus tard la survie est bonne
très peu d'arbres n'ont pas passé
l'hiver petite clin d'oeil l'année
dernière on a mis des Lilas japonais ah
oui celui-là
[Musique]
et au bout d'un an à peine on voit déjà
une nouvelle biodiversité qui s'installe
là où jadis il n'y avait que du gazon